Some languages ​​have scary long words!
Hawaii has been directly cut off from people's driving. . . first name.
An ancient comedian spelled the meat dish of this mystery class.
And the German word can become so long that it lost its longest word in 2013.
Almost no traces left.
So what is going on with these words? How long can a word be?
A few years ago, I lived this life,
Ten hours a day, I went to a table, worked on weekends, and went for lunch breaks.
Snorkeling with sea turtles in the coral reef!
Oh, did I not mention that I was lying on a table in Hawaii?
So I had a very enjoyable swim and I was heading home.
I must have been fascinated by the scenery, singing with the birds or something, because somewhere
I turned the wrong way.
So now I am facing this never-ending street card.
Seriously, the letters continue to do so!
In this case, if you are a normal person, you will know that you are lost, so you turned around.
Take another route.
But linguistic nerd?
We threw away our ice cream and sat there fascinated by phonemes.
Oh, do you think that a man alone will roam the street while walking and licking ice cream?
That's really creepy!
No, we eat ice.
The most interesting thing is that if you open a Hawaiian dictionary, you will never find such an infinitely long word.
In fact, most of the terms look very short.
So where does this extra letter come from?
Play with me for a while and you will hear taboos from the Pacific island countries.
Oh, there are some interesting "kapu" stories, but this is a story.
So remember "kapu", but now look at the syllable "ho'o". This is called verb in my grammar book.
Add "kapu" and you will get "ho'okapu", which may mean making a thing sacred or taboo.
But these affixes only add a few letters to us, and they make me "grammar headache", so
This is not a big victory.
In addition, most Hawaiian grammars are made up of separate small parts called particles.
And if you think that anatomy of the "letter monster" is a painful process, here is a chance for you to tame a group
The word "insects" everywhere!
But how beautiful they are.
Is there anything longer than adding it to your base words by adding some attachments?
Add another basic word!
This is called a compound word and it will win you a lot of extra letters.
Is there a flaw?
Have a brain?
How about the lightning brain! (computer)
This is some feces from the spray. (sulfur)
Why not a blunt pig nose nose squid!
Amazing words to build, Hawaii.
So, is Hawaii the longest word in history?
It is
No.
So what about German or Greek mentioned before?
The same strategy: compound words, compound words, compound words...
Unfortunately, there are no record-breakers here.
This award belongs to... Drums from l ....
a master of compound words, a 16th century writer,
She uses compound words to have an entire chapter in her Sanskrit masterpiece.
Go and say, "So this person passed the part of passing Tamil Nadu."
But she rushed through the area, I mean she really focused on the place.
One of them (just one!) describes the gorgeous Sanskrit word in this place.
Dozens of compound words.
This is how the Sanskrit compound is used to make the longest word on the Guinness Book of World Records.
Are we celebrating a special moment?
Does this idea also flash your mind: in theory, can we always add
Compound words with hyphens?
Ah, you are right!
It’s not fair, right?
If we just play this, it's good.
This is a hyphenal verbal speed race.
The problem with these words is that they are not really used.
The truth is that even if there are compound words, Hawaiian German, or even Sanskrit, they have not won.
Any average number of letters in the game.
Around the world, where do people really use long words for almost every sentence?
Oh, they built a completely different way to build words.
When should I go back to that point.
Keep watching and subscribe to language videos!